fuentes arrasados casas inundadas y
devastación así quedó la isla francesa
de guadalupe en el caribe tras el paso
de la tormenta tropical fiona en alerta
roja por fuertes lluvias y tormentas
eléctricas
se lo pongo a este es el puente de goya
ve el río se lo ha llevado si ve su
altura en relación con el agua el nivel
del agua debió subir al menos 35 metros
invadió todo el valle e inundó las casas
de la gente muy bien me tatuarse con las
lluvias excepcionales desde el viernes
han hecho subir el nivel del agua hasta
un metro y medio y han provocado cortes
de luz y agua en la región y otras
fallas en los sistemas que han afectado
a al menos 10.000 usuarios como en el
caso de estela del hongo que ahora
intenta sacar el agua de su casa tras la
explosión de un contado
y
los despertaron a las dos de la mañana
porque el contador explotó así que nos
levantamos y vimos que el agua empezaba
a subir en casa tiene una hora teníamos
80 centímetros de agua dentro
de
este archipiélago de las antillas
menores ya había sufrido inundaciones a
finales de abril que dejaron al menos un
muerto y estado de catástrofe natural en
varios municipios con fenómenos cada vez
más recurrentes que los expertos achacan
a la crisis climática ahora con este
nuevo temporal el gobierno local ha
instado a los ciudadanos a permanecer en
sus casas y se han suspendido la mayoría
de las actividades ya que se espera que
el fenómeno meteorológico formado en la
cuenca del atlántico no termine hasta el
domingo en la mañana